wir wollen über eine zweite große krise
sprechen eine krise der kanzlerschaft
angela merkels die flüchtlingskrise
aktuell ja wieder mehr als 1000
flüchtlinge pro tag über polen oder über
die balkanroute zu uns nach deutschland
gerade in diesen tagen erinnern wir uns
wieder an diesen berühmten satz der
bundeskanzlerin
und ich sage ganz einfach deutschland
ist ein starkes land und die das motiv
in dem wir an diese dinge herangehen
muss muss sein wir haben so vieles
geschafft wir schaffen das wir schaffen
das und wir haben im übrigen in den
letzten elf monaten sehr sehr viel
bereits
geschaffen dass der berühmte satz der
bundeskanzlerin wahrscheinlich der
berühmteste satz der bundeskanzlerin in
ihrer kanzlerschaft und jetzt hat sie
den eigenen satz nochmal weiter
getrieben sie hat gesagt in einem
interview mit der deutschen welle ja wir
haben das geschafft was für ein satz zum
ende ihrer kanzlerschaft als abrechnung
unter die flüchtlingskrise sagt die
kanzlerin jetzt ja wir haben das
geschafft
während
ja wir wollen sozusagen den check machen
heute wir wollen nämlich genau dorthin
gehen wo sich aktuell die
flüchtlingskrise noch abspielt vor
unseren türen wir wollen gehen zu
unserer bild reporterin diana das büro
polo die seit jahren auf den spuren der
flüchtlinge ist und jetzt hat sie
mehrere wochen an der
griechisch-türkischen grenze verbracht
und auch an der grenze zu albanien und
zu mazedonien hat genau dort
recherchiert
während alle augen auf die grenzen
polens gerichtet sind steigen die
migrationsströme aus griechenland nach
nordeuropa szenen die einen
flüchtlingsstrom von 2015 erinnern der
fluss evros türkei und griechenland in
den vergangenen jahren kamen vernetzte
kein nach deutschland mehr als 1,2
millionen geflüchtete bild exklusiv
zugang zu den patrol in der griechischen
armee infos an der grenze zur türkei
bild reporterin jannis büro polo war für
uns vor ort bilden das wir haben gesehen
wie sich menschen in lastwagen
versteckten verhaftet wurden und es
immer wieder versuchten und sie werden
nie aufhören bis sie ihr endgültiges
ziel erreichen frankreich england
österreich und natürlich deutschland oft
sehr man die sogenannte balkanroute
bleibt nicht nur offen es gibt doch
einen anstieg der illegalen
grenzübergänge um 20 bis 30 prozent
unzählige streitkräfte und
grenzpolizisten patroullieren einen
griechisch türkischen grenzfluss evros
ausgerüstet mit spürhunden ferngläser
und wärmebildkameras und drohen
versuchen die streitkräfte die
geflüchteten aufzuhalten etwas weiter
eine griechische panischen grenze trifft
bild-reporter alias europa mit auf eine
gruppe aus syrien die mit hilfe von
schleusern weiter nach deutschland
reisen will
[Applaus]
wir sind in der nähe der albanischen
grenze und haben eine gruppe männer aus
syrien getroffen sie haben bereits einen
versuch hinter sich der ihn misslungen
ist nun wollen die flüchtlinge es wieder
über die grenze nach albanien schaffen
[Musik]
albanien ist nicht gut für flüchtlinge
wir wollen weiter nicht dort bleiben wir
wollen nicht in albanien kosovo oder
serbien bleiben wir wollen weiter nach
europa nach deutschland
in dieser ruine an der griechischen
grenze haben die männer vorerst ihre
zelte aufgeschlagen hier hausen die
geflüchteten unter menschenunwürdigen
bedingungen bis sie den nächsten flucht
versucht nach nordeuropa staaten lian
astropolis trifft auf den hafenmeister
constantinos carydis sein team
kontrolliert den hafen von igoumenitsa
ihr ziel illegale geflüchtete aufspüren
wir haben in diesem jahr 520 flüchtlinge
festgenommen im vergangenen jahr waren
es 570 flüchtlinge die wir festgenommen
haben die geflüchteten wollen mit allen
mitteln nach italien auch sein
fluchtversuch es im lkw auf eine der
fähren zu schaffen scheiterte die
meisten von ihnen werden auf ihrer route
aufgegriffen zurück in die türkei oder
in umliegende camps geschickt denn noch
passieren immer wieder geflüchtete die
grenze auch wenn die streitkräfte vor
ort sind um sie daran zu hindern und
unsere kollegin diana ist büro polo ist
uns jetzt aus kriegen ein zugeschaltet
juliana du hast mehrere wochen an den
grenzübergängen griechenlands
recherchiert und wir haben gerade in
kurzen einblick in deiner arbeit
erhalten was hast du dort alles vor ort
erlebt
es war für mich wirklich überrascht ist
er überraschend dass wir dort so viele
geflüchtete angetroffen haben die
versucht haben von griechenland aus die
grenze zu übertreten um nach
mitteleuropa oder nach deutschland zu
kommen wir dachten dass die alle in
polen sein dass das die neue rote wäre
aber das ist nicht so die balkanroute
bleibt offen
und was wir dort mit unseren eigenen
augen gesehen haben ist das in der
region um den fluss das heißt an der
grenzregion zur türkei
die armee wirklich alles tut was sie tun
kann um die grenzen griechenlands und
europas vor diesen neuen
flüchtlingsströmen zu schützen aber es
scheint nicht auszureichen und zwar aus
zwei gründen
[Musik]
zunächst einmal ist der grenzverlauf ein
sehr langer und zweitens sind diese
menschen verzweifelt und sie sind
entschlossen
wir haben in ihrer menge menschen
getroffen das ist also eine bekannte
treffpunkte für menschen auf der
balkanroute und wir haben dort menschen
betroffen die bereits acht mal versucht
haben über den evros nach griechenland
zu kommen und sie haben es zum teil noch
geschafft sie sind also sehr
entschlossen und dann haben wir sie dort
auf dieser balkan route weiter verfolgt
in richtung deutschland
und das wohl
bemerkenswerteste oder merkwürdigste ist
dass trotz all der anstrengung der armee
man in der grenzregion keine
grenzbeamten oder polizisten getroffen
hat um diese balkan route abzuschirmen
oder auch die anderen routen die nach
norden verlaufen wir haben nur zwei
polizeiautos gesehen und zwar auf den
hauptstraßen ein paar straßen sperren
aber nichts in den bergen in den
waldgebieten um diesen grenzverlauf zu
schützen und das war wirklich merkwürdig
es war als schiene es niemandem wirklich
wichtig ob diese leute aus griechenland
herbst wandern
das heißt es ist möglicherweise egal
weil die wollen ja sowieso größtenteils
nach deutschland weiter da lässt man sie
halt ziehen
natürlich wissen wir
ganz geflüchteten die nach griechenland
kommen nicht hier bleiben wollen da gibt
es für sie nichts zu finden wir wissen
dass griechenland noch immer unter druck
steht oder nicht so sehr wie 2015 und
das geht auf die finanzkrise zurück das
heißt wir als stadt haben einfach keine
mittel um das zur verfügung zu stellen
was die geflüchteten menschen brauchen
und auch was die menschen in
griechenland überhaupt brauchen und das
wissen die geflüchteten deswegen wollen
sie nicht in griechenland bleiben sie
wollen auch nicht in albanien und
mazedonien bleiben sie möchten nach
deutschland oder in die nördlichen
staaten
die bedingungen sind
sie verstecken sich in den wäldern sie
haben entweder unterschlupf in ruinen
gefunden oder haben so etwas wie klein
unterstände es ist kalt vielleicht nicht
ganz so kalt wie in polen und das mag
auch einer der gründe sein weshalb wir
jetzt schon fast eben solche zahlen
wieder haben
also gestiegen sind wir haben jetzt auch
gesehen was die leute da gegessen habe
in dem filmbeitrag es ist keine gute
situation was sagen die all diese
menschen wo wollen sie hin und du wirst
mit ihnen auch über zukunft sprechen was
stellen sie sich vor was wünschen sie
sich was wovon träumen sie
nun sie wünschen sich
zunächst einmal hauptsächlich dass sie
ein normales leben führen können
und da geht es dann entweder darum dass
sie geschützt sind vor kriegen oder dass
sie keine ganz normale arbeitsstelle für
sich finden für die jüngeren ist es dass
sie zur schule gehen zur uni gehen
wollen um ein normales leben führen zu
können und das ist etwas was sie in
ihren heimatländern nicht schaffen
können jetzt haben wir heute gesprochen
über einen neuen satz der kanzlerin der
berühmte satz von ihr der es uns allen
noch vor augen wir schaffen das jetzt
sagt sie in einem interview mit der
deutschen welle ganz aktuell ja wir
haben das geschafft wie ist dein
eindruck wenn du diesen satz hörst und
jetzt selber
schade aus dem grenzgebiet dort kommt
natürlich hat deutschland sehr viel
geleistet in dieser flüchtlingsfrage und
wir wissen auch dass deutschland einlass
land ist in dem sehr sehr viele von
diesen geflüchteten menschen ankommen
nach wie vor ein großer teil und ich
glaube das wird nie aufwand diese
management werden weiterhin versuchen
über griechenland auch nach deutschland
zukommt ganz gleich was die kanzlerin
sagt ganz gleich was die griechischen
behörden dazu sagen das wird so nicht
aufhören weil die menschen verzweifelt
sind unsere reporterin lernbüro polo
vielen herzlichen dank für deine
einschätzungen
und bei uns im studio ist jetzt bild
parlamentsbüro leiter ralf schuler er
berichtet seit jahren über die kanzlerin
wir müssen also über diese zwei sätze
die er zusammen hängen ja geschaffen
dass und die wärme es geschafft einmal
diskutieren wie schätzt du das ein was
geht da wirklich in der kanzlerin vor
ist es so etwas was jetzt zum ende der
kanzlerschaft wenn man noch mal positiv
bilanz ziehen oder schätze die lage
wirklich genauso eines man sagt ja wenn
es geschafft nun ist es ja menschlich
nicht ganz unverständlich wenn man sich
selbst zeugnis ausstellt dass die dann
meistens besser ausfallen als wenn es
andere tun die kanzlerin kann natürlich
nicht sich aus dem amt verabschieden mit
der bilanz ja ich hab leider versagt das
wird man psychologisch verstehen
sie hat immer einen anderen blick auf
die migrations krise gehabt ich erinnere
mich an 20.15 wir waren zusammen
unterwegs und sie hat immer einen sehr
detaillierten einen sehr technischen
blick ab sie kannte sich am geländer
normgrößen in kasernen erinnern die
mussten erhöht werden damit flüchtlinge
untergebracht werden sie hat wie kabel
durch brandschutz bauern geführt werden
also sehr technisch und auch
finanztechnisch im bundeshaushalt der
große bogen der da zu schlagen war
kulturell gesellschaftspolitisch das ist
ein sehr viel dickere brett und da haben
wir sicherlich noch längst nicht alles
geschafft wir reden über diesen satz an
einem tag an dem wir selber auf unserer
seite drei heute groß berichten über die
kriminalität die auch teilweise eben mit
ins land gekommen ist in diesen jahren
der flüchtlings anteil organisierte
kriminalität der hat sich in den
vergangen den jahren eben fast
verdoppelt und genau in diese
nachrichtenlage fällt dieser satz der
kanzlerin du lebst selber auf dem land
kann es vielleicht auch fühlen wie
dieser satz ankommt was würdest du sagen
ja wir haben es geschafft wie kommt
dieser satz also das ist ein ganz gutes
stichwort was du ansprichst in den
großstädten wo die probleme meistens
nicht so groß sichtbar werden kommt der
satz sicherlich ganz gut an dort haben
wir auch die
metropolen milieus die damals geklatscht
haben da funktioniert vieles auf dem
land ist das eher schwieriger da gibt es
gerade im osten große skepsis und da
wird man dass er als hohn empfinden
diese kriminalitätsstatistik ist ja nur
ein aspekt wir hatten es gesehen in der
korona krise dass die intensivstationen
und die hospitalisierung sehr stark
migrantische geprägt war wir haben seit
jahren den fakt dass gefängnisse einen
sehr starken anteil von menschen mit
migrationshintergrund haben wir haben in
den großstädten allerdings auch
stadtviertel die mehr und mehr migranten
geprägt sind und wir haben einen und man
will kulturellen effekt dass wir einen
ganz neuen meldung stil haben
großfamilien gehen aufeinander zu oder
männer gehen mit messer aufeinander wo
der kundige thema weiß da ist meistens
migration mit dem spiel und wir haben
seit einiger zeit ein ganz neues
lagebild messer kriminalität was es vor
dem großen migrationswelle nicht gegeben
hat wir holen in unser gespräch rainer
wendt als zuerst bundesvorsitzender der
deutschen polizeigewerkschaft
ihnen einen schönen guten tag wie
bewerten sie den merkel satz ja wir
haben es geschafft ist dieser satz für
sie haltbar
ich dass ich gemeint war mit wir und was
wir denn eigentlich nun schaffen sollten
also
tatsache ist dass viele menschen mit
dieser migrationspolitik nach wie vor
nicht zurechtkommen und tatsache ist
auch dass die unkontrollierte
zuwanderung nach deutschland und europa
weiter anhält wir haben die massenhafte
integration nicht geschafft wir haben es
nicht geschafft europa in eine linie zu
bringen und wir schaffen es nach wie vor
nicht die außengrenzen und auch die
binnengrenzen zu kontrollieren so dass
illegale migration nach deutschland und
europa unterbunden werden also es gibt
einige wenige gute beispiele von
integrationsleistungen diesen alle
erfreulich aber zu sagen wir haben es
geschafft das ist weit übertrieben und
ich sage es mal ein bisschen will ich
das auch empfinde ein typische
politische form von selbstgerechtigkeit
selbstgerechtigkeit sagt rainer wendt
vielleicht können wir trotzdem noch mal
mit den positiven dingen ganz kurz
abschließend also was haben wir denn
geschafft gibt es etwas bei dem sie
sagen würden ja seit 2.15 16 das hat
sich echt dramatisch verbessert oder das
ist unsere leistung
unsere leistung besteht vor allem darin
die menschen aufgenommen zu haben und
sie hier bei uns vernünftig zu versorgen
sie sind in den unterkünften sind
teilweise auf wohnungen verteilt worden
und vieles andere mehr das hat kein
anderes land der welt in dieser form
geschafft das heißt so viele menschen in
so kurzer zeit unterzubringen und zu
versorgen sie werden medizinisch
versorgt es werden jede menge angebote
von integrationskursen sprachkursen
schulen und lehrgängen gemacht da muss
deutschland überhaupt kein schlechtes
gewissen haben sondern im gegenteil das
ist an sich schon eine große leistung
tatsache ist aber auch dass sich
deutschland und sie haben ja als
kriminalitäts bild angesprochen auch in
negativer hinsicht verändert hat sowohl
was die entwicklung selber angeht aber
auch was die furcht vor kriminalität
angeht wir haben viele dinge dazu
beigetragen ich erinnere machen können
also wird dann hat das hat bleibende
spuren in der kriminalitätsfurcht
deutschen hinterlassen was muss getan
werden damit die integration gelingen
kann und
zunächst einmal muss man die kontrolle
der jugendlichen die in unser land
kommen verbessern wir wissen ja nach wie
vor nicht wieder in unser land kommt ihr
weiteres jahr angesprochen dass die
routen nach wie vor offen sind menschen
schlagen sich durch entweder wenn sie
über die zentrale mediterraner route
gekommen sind irgendwie die balkanroute
oder über die osteuropäische route
kommen dann irgendwie nach europa und
schlagen sich dann nach deutschland
durch weil deutschland nach wie vor
anreize bieten in unser land zu kommen
das muss sich dringend ändern sonst
werden wir nie eine integration schaffen
und dann müssen wir diejenigen
zurückführen die definitiv kein recht
haben in unserem land zu bleiben
deutschland muss ernst machen mit der
ankündigung die ja nun auch einmal
rechtslage ist dass diejenigen wieder
zurückgeführt werden in ihre länder die
keinen aufenthaltsstatus hier bekommen
oder sehe ich ehrlich gesagt schwarz
denn das haben wir ja auch nicht
geschafft die rückführung derjenigen
werden zwar immer wieder menschen
abgeschoben aber unter großem trara und
bei weitem nicht in der anzahl die
eigentlich sinnvoll und notwendig wäre